[Musica]
sono massimo antonelli ho avuto la
fortuna di fare una bella carriera nel
mondo del basket
ho vinto uno scudetto una coppa italia a
bologna anche svariate presenze con le
nazionali giovanili e senior ho vinto
una medaglia di bronzo ai giochi del
mediterraneo ad algeri molti anni fa poi
conseguito una laurea in architettura e
ha incominciato anche ad allenare
purtroppo questa laurea che lettura mi è
servita a di storia dello sport ho
cominciato ad allenare i giovani e poi
ho creato un metodo music basket ball
metodo che cos'è è un innovativo
divertente ed efficace metodo che
utilizza la musica per insegnare i
fondamentali del basket e per migliorare
anche le capacità tecniche e motorie
degli atleti
poi a un certo punto della mia vita ho
sentito un desiderio un forte desiderio
di ritornare qualcosa all'ambiente che
mi ha cresciuto
gli americani la chiamano giving back
filosofi ossia per qualcosa che anima
gli sportivi di successo di aiutare
quelle comunità più bisognose e questo
lo fanno come forma di riconoscenza
ecco questo desiderio l'ho voluto
condividere con degli amici
tre mesi di quindi tre mesi sono proprio
tutti i giocatori con la mia stessa
voglia di dare qualcosa indietro e poi
c'è anche mio fratello un grandissimo
non ho mai giocato ma grandissimo amante
del basket e abbiamo fondato 25 tan tan
basketball un'associazione sportiva che
è andata ad operare dove ce n'è più
bisogno
a castelvolturno a castelvolturno si è
insediata la più grande comunità in
percentuale di africani d'europa circa
il 50 per cento e nel continente
africano e noi abbiamo rivolto la nostra
attenzione proprio ai figli di questi
immigrati che nessuno di questi a casa
nessuno un paese la sport perché i
genitori non potevano permetterselo
ecco che il nostro intervento in questa
zona ha una nota una doppia valenza
la prima è quella di coprire un buco
sociale la seconda è quella di dare pari
opportunità a dei ragazzi che altrimenti
non potevano fare sport è una storia
triste ma è nata così tante en plus che
inizia la sua attività sui campi
giusto tre anni fa il 22 di ottobre del
2016 quando per la prima volta dei
ragazzini entrava molto timidamente su
un campo da basket in una palestra
scolastica al villaggio coppola subito
mi accorgo che questi ragazzi non
avevano niente della disciplina un caos
tremendo su quel campo nonostante io
avessi un'esperienza colossale perché
con quel metodo io faccio corsi ho fatto
corso in poi in tutto il mondo
immediamente alleno allenavo mille 500
ragazze all'anno non riusciva a gestirle
perché questi ragazzi se non sapevo
niente del comportamento che bisogna
tenere durante un allenamento chiamò in
soccorso
una mia amica docente psicologia
sportiva sia individuale che di gruppo
annamaria metter angelis lei non si fa
pregare viene subito in palestra e
quando incomincia dice la vera mente le
incomincia a girare intorno al campo
mezz'ora un'ora e non mi dice nulla
un'ora e mezza e non mi dice niente
all'inter mi sorprende se ne va io
rimango così l'italia mente la prima
cosa che faccio quando arriva a casa che
la mamma maria e lei mi dice massimo va
bene così state donando gioia non potete
far di più va bene così in effetti
questi ragazzi quando giocano sorridono
però io dopo quattro mesi mi sono dovuto
operare alle corde vocali
questi ragazzi arrivavamo sempre
editarla perché perché loro direttamente
da scuola non andava neanche a casa a
mangiare perché tutti quanti vengono in
palestra piedi
nessuno viene accompagnato mai una cosa
incredibile allora quelli tardi di 15 30
45 minuti per me li dovrà accettare
nonostante sia naturalmente un
professionista di questo mondo è la
regola del rispettare l'orario della
dell'allenamento è sacra ma niente ho
dovuto accettare questo compromesso però
un giorno arriva victor un'ora e mezza
di ritardo cioè a quel punto il
professionista ritorna dice no qui è
troppo non passa lo chiamo victor iniqua
allora sembra possibile che arrivi loro
e mezzo di ritardo e lui mi fa coach
coach massimo vi aspettate
sono passati due pullman sulla strada ma
c'era il controllore sopra e io non
potevo salire
ho dovuto aspettare il testo che poter
venire in palestra
ecco quello è stato l'esatto momento in
cui io ho pensato questo progetto da
sportivo deve diventare sociale ho
subito chiamato i soci dicendo questa
cosa e allora non solo era l'attività
sportiva che ci regalavamo enrico di
annunciato a pensare di offrire tutto
abbigliamento scarpe le viste mediche
tutto ciò che poteva esserci incomincia
il mio primo il nostro più è tanta ma
come fare per rifornire a questi ragazzi
che venivano in palestra con veramente
alcuni sono venuti con delle pantofole
invernali dello scatto che spesso si
aprirono caprino che giocavano anche a
piedi scalzi 1 si è presentato mi
ricordo il giorno con polacchina con un
carnet carro armato alto così col pil
all'interno
i ragazzi non avevano proprio
abbigliamento sportivo allora facciamo
abbiamo bisogno di materiale è arrivato
di tutto da tutte le parti d'italia
una magia è arrivato tanto materiale che
veramente non sapevo neanche come più
distribuirlo addirittura sono arrivati
di libri dei libri consegnati a mano da
milano cose veramente che uno dice c'è
un cuore grande e in questo mondo
dobbiamo solamente stanno fuori
allora però quando le cose sono andate
bene spesso c'è qualcosa che magari si
intoppa mi chiama una mesi della preside
della scuola e mi dice coach antonelli
non ci dispiace ma non potete più venire
in palestra perché per che incominciano
i progetti pomeridiane per la mazzetta
incredibile castelvolturno ma non ci
sono spazi dove potersi allenare
era un meno un po impaurito lancia volta
ha detto giro che facciamo del sud
informa la paura spesso anela sportivo
posso parlare la paura un elemento s'è
preso bene è un preziosissimo elemento
per migliorare per migliorare la
prestazione sportiva in questo caso
recentemente mi aiutato quella quel
modus di fare quando giocavo in questa
operazione ha detto siamo senza un campo
cosa fare non si allenano ai ragazzi
ecco qui a chiedere in giro mi dicono
che c'è uno spazio in riva al mare dove
c'era un campo sembra all'aperto vai a
vedere
vado a vederlo la vita un campo con un
c'è uno spazio completamente abbandonato
a terra l'assalto bot ordinato erba
dappertutto c'era anche la santa in
questo perché a riva al mare su questo
campo e poi senza canestri però
naturalmente non si potevano abbattere
in due giorni sono riusciti a renderlo
agibile per fare gli allenamenti quando
tu cominci in pieno marzo ad allenare
dei ragazzi fanno da poco tempo il
basket dice ma con questo freddo che fa
è possibile che questi ragazzi non
abbandonino era molto ero poco convinto
che i ragazzi potessero rimanere a fare
allenamento quelle condizioni all'aperto
riva al mare
e invece no i ragazzi sono aumentati di
numero
un giorno comincia a piovere in cui a
piovere
vabbè giochiamo ancora c'è un po più
forte sempre più forte io mi aspettavo
che i ragazzi in senso qui ma allora
cosa qui non ci può sempre allenare il
palleggio non esiste più
si scivola di sé niente imperterriti
continuavano a giocare ecco che io
chiamo ha certo punto 30 per trovare un
riparo sotto una tettoia
ho fatto una figuraccia pessima
immaginate però però in quel momento ho
capito che il passaggio del testimone
della passione da me era avvenuto
questi ragazzi in questo momento hanno
mostrato più passione di chi gliel'aveva
trasmessa ed è stato un episodio molto
bello da questa siena di pioggia li
voglio viso e portare una cosa che loro
amano molti dei kemp dicembre l'ente una
cosa che loro un aspetto moltissimo
si fa sempre su questo campo all'aperto
non però amici di stare solo due ore tre
ore per fare un allenamento non ci
stanno 7 8 ore
non c'è il riparo non c'è possibilità di
prendere ombra sole cocente e stando a
contatto coi ragazzi capisci anche quali
sono le loro tabù per esempio alcune
avevano problemi con il coraggio di
togliersi la maglietta paura alcuni non
si buttavano in acqua dal popolo
dell'acqua
adesso guai quando il internet entrano
in acqua non itil it fuori dal proprio
insomma ecco allora
facciamo una riflessione
secondo me è proprio questo lo sport il
gioco di squadra
questo confronto continuo con sé coi
compagni che con gli avversari
ecco che questo facilita inizio di mina
istanbul linea queste paure e facilita
la crescita dell'autostima
a settembre di due anni fa
vado a iscrivere la squadra al
campionato under 14 con la federazione
italiana pallacanestro e arriva una
notizia pessima che non possono giocare
più di due stranieri per squadra
la nostra squadra è formata da tutti i
ragazzi che sono figli sono nati si in
italia ma in quanti in quanto figli di
stranieri sono anch'essi stranieri e
quindi non potevano giocare paura
terrore e di sembrava una cosa assurda
che lo che la scuola include e lo sport
esclude voi poi ve la sentireste di
bloccare nei ragazzi che sorridono così
mentre giocano bestie nere
quell'entusiasmo quella di nascita era
qualcosa di atroce che stanno
stabilizzando in questa società facciamo
un tanta un'altra porta con tanta
cerchiamo di farlo sapere in giro questa
notizia qui che era veramente
bruttissima e la raccoglie all'inizio un
un giornalista un genesi del luogo che
scrive sul mattino cronaca di caserta e
su un piccolo articolo e tino scotti al
finimondo dopo alcuni giorni in quello
spazio là dove ci allenavamo noi è
venuto di tutto tutti i miei di hackney
12 volte telegiornale che è successo non
abbiamo avuto paura di trasmettere
questa cosa
agli atti ci hanno aiutato come quelli
tutte quelle immagini che trasmetteva
una televisione che nonostante i ragazzi
stessero vivendo un momento drammatico
che porti non potevano giocare
noi avremo sempre la gioia del gioco dei
sorrisi sono stati vincenti perché ha
colpito di kiko per le coscienze di chi
governa lo sport che ci hanno offerto la
possibilità di giocare in deroga
poi addirittura dopo due mesi a dicembre
il governo italiano inserisce nella
legge di bilancio
una norma che recita su per giù così
qualsiasi cittadino straniero minorenne
il bis sul suolo italiano da almeno un
anno ne frequenta le scuole nello sport
deve essere considerato come gli
italiani senza nessun aggravio
ecco questa donna che è stata ispirata
da noi oggi permette a 800 mila ragazzi
minorenni stranieri di poter fare sport
grazie insomma permette a 800 mila
ragazzi di fare sport come gli italiani
poi un'altra cosa che così a voglio dire
che quest'anno ma sapete come è stata
chiamata la norma salva tan tan basket è
stata mutuata così ecco che la storia di
ragazzini è diventata come una favola
naturalmente è già tutto vediamo
mediaticamente una mattina ecco che al 5
hd una brutta notizia sento che arriva
dal tribunale di santa maria capua
vetere una telefonata sono il magistrato
senza coach antonelli e lei si sente che
c'è il mio imbarazzo io subito pensato a
qualche il mio ragazzo ha combinato un
fattaccio qualcosa di brutto perché è
invece fa stia tranquillo antonelli
perché io sono la coach della squadra
nazionale magistrati e noi vorremmo fare
una partita con voi contro di voi per
dare anche un grande segnale di legalità
in una zona martoriata dalla camorra
e così è stato sono venuti abbiamo fatto
una partita
secondo voi chi è caduto c'è stato
l'arbitro che non ha fischiato neanche
un fallo contro contro i magistrati i
miei ragazzi timidi e ci hanno provato
ma poi hanno capito che era meglio dirsi
li pone è arrivata una telefonata anche
della comunità del piacenza la comunità
ghanese della provincia di caserta e c
che mi dice così coach senti si presenta
e mi disse noi ogni anno facciamo la
festa e mettiamo un po di soldi la cui
siamo stati per che tacciano ballo
mangiamo eccetera
quest'anno abbiamo pensato di
raccogliere soldi da di rinunciare alla
festa comprare dei doni e portali e
ragazze una cosa meravigliosa veramente
meravigliosa
ecco poi il 16 giugno di quest arma
una data che non posso mai scordare
poiché capirete perché la squadra under
15 ha vinto allenata da vittorio scotto
d'antoni d'antoni di strano ha vinto il
titolo regionale campano una festa nella
festa perché era anche il giorno del mio
compleanno
non ci poteva essere un regalo più bello
provate a immaginare ecco lì ho pensato
che tre anni di grandi sacrifici e tanta
strada fatta a piedi ecco che la grande
ricompensa spesso two cities valorosi fa
nel grande impegno e la costanza spesso
portano veramente alle grandi risultati
anche in poco tempo e questo magicamente
era successo ma i miei ragazzi
adesso ho tre desideri il primo che nel
mondo non ci sia mai più una barriera
che ostacoli il gioco ai ragazzi
il secondo è che si costruisca un
villaggio sportivo perché perché io ogni
giorno arrivano di bimbi che vorrebbero
iniziare a giocare non posso
purtroppo venderli con me per quale
motivo perché non abbiamo uno spazio per
poter far giocare questi ragazzi è primo
anche qui un grande e tan tan di aiuto
chiedono aiuto terzo è questo che un
giorno qualcuno dei ragazzi che è
cresciuto e si è formato con noi siete
creek a mente che umanamente abbia
successo
un grandissimo successo e che torna a
castelvolturno e che mi dica ok coach
adesso rilassati perché ci penso io a
tanta
[Applauso]
[Musica]